sup everyone hipster pew is back with
this class and apparently I compute you
you that you guys are probably Commodore
only like a million times already but
apparently that looks like a vagina and
every time I wash it apparently you can
save this [ __ ] game and there
supposed to be a warning or something I
haven't seen that [ __ ] warning so
thank you and I bet what you're thinking
you're probably thinking like oh so
Peter will head it out the stuff will
replace it
think again [ __ ] that we're in this
together you know
no series I'm not gonna edit anything if
I have to replay it you [ __ ] we watch
it I know what's happening
wake up Jesus Christ
spin around
it's [ __ ] oh this is a voice from
apart sounds like a guy oh also that's
what I heard in the lost time
let's together look at it it is still
like a category B even though I know I'm
fine
this part
I wonder if you could save the guy like
if there's a way to save it
you guys are probably commented on it
there whoa whoa whoa whoa penis penis
penis penis penis penis penis what the
[ __ ] I forgot about him oh [ __ ] it
didn't see me uh he wants to watch me
oh [ __ ] I'm out of here
wait what am I going oh [ __ ] he's going
he's coming after me is coming at me
he's coming up he's gonna ask me Oh
penis I'm [ __ ] yup
good thinking these I hear footsteps I
hear footsteps
is so sexy
okay good holy [ __ ]
completely forgot about that okay we get
stick that action so if you die in this
game you have to replay the entire
[ __ ] thing that's super different
it's fancy
oh shut up no never winning here right
see masturbating
Bible
Oh buckets so nothing in here what's up
with these freaking rooms I don't get it
we weren't where we here Oh No
forgive me all right just seeing my love
I know I'm not as telling this mall may
hello or strong-ass Bastile but I'm
sorry my love is true do not scars tell
you so I will continue to cut myself as
long as I wait didn't I read this [ __ ]
is this
it's basically nothing in their [ __ ]
now can you hear me it's not too late to
set things right tell me what to do that
it's ticking sound I'm right here
alright I'll [ __ ] kill you man sorry
got a text hey we're back
please please me were there to do this
nope well how do I solve it that any
[ __ ] ideas Jesus Christ is so lazy
alright dad is that all you have to say
wait did I go in kay it's very good
snakes and whatnot I hate this tunnel I
hate this so much
it sounds like he's right behind me
those free car I don't like the Sun
let's go backwards actually
see if they actually expand never mind
that
ah it's so disturbing ah
I remember the way now
I wonder if there is anything oh let's
not listen to her it's not a pro let's
take another round this time did I go
down here yeah all right
the downstairs library was still
reminded that a minor or father all
those hours spent there had a foster the
sense of she'll do I still have no I
don't have my items it's so stupid I
have to reload everything some reason
let's try and say that guy but priest or
whatever loss tinderbox yeah i miss
dolls math [ __ ]
wait is there oh there it is
oopsie hold on me I swear it's not a hat
oh my god it's an epic pirate hat it
no it's not
nothing here I don't know what's up with
these they don't come alive I don't
all right who are you who's there it's
me it's not how he lies I can see your
penis
everyone food don't say that I didn't do
anything
his balls is bigger than its penis oh
dude I was just kidding don't be that
just said about it in the box
I'm guessing this isn't open yeah you
can see underneath set that up take this
book love books it's so much
actually I don't I don't accept the
Twilight Saga I love that the same team
take up all the way what we never went
in here that we how sweet there's like
stuff here what is this oh that's
awesome
whoa no
no no no wait a minute
someone trying to come in here bad idea
nevermind bad idea let's get the [ __ ]
out it is hitting all [ __ ] ok let's
hurry hurry all right huh penis penis
penis penis penis penis
my supposed to go
oh I don't like that song at all ah stop
making that sound it's all there this is
there anything in there there's like
nothing to do in this [ __ ] game
stop adding the dark something behind no
I guess we gotta kill the big ball
priests to improve you called me names
so now your that won't happen are they
like stretching him or something yeah
but it sounds like I'm learning
something mm-hmm actually not
necessarily all right you explaining as
Oh
all right so this continue our journey
playing the game what have we already
played Julius let's play ever
[Music]